I wonder if there's a sortie hat for
gender and sexuality so yes I am talking
about LGBTQ plus representation in media
which does mean first of all we'll swap
the look out so if you're new or haven't
seen these sorts of videos from me
before my name is Nathaniel and I have a
certain amount of fluidity when it comes
to my own personal sense of gender you
may also have noticed that I am wearing
the hard work shirt and flying my house
colors so that means we are also talking
about Harry Potter I debated for a while
as to whether to dedicate an entire
video to this or to use it as part of a
larger discussion on representation in
general and I am gonna put it in context
but I feel like this is something kind
of needs its own videos because the
Harry Potter franchise is fairly unique
but you know like I said I'll put it in
some other contexts as well so when it
comes to talking about lgbtq+
representation I've talked about Harry
Potter a few times primarily in the
context of the continued failure to
confirm author JK Rowling's assertion
that Professor Albus Dumbledore is gay
in the actual text of any of the works
but I want to use Harry Potter as a way
to point out how isolating a lack of
representation can feel by giving this
issue a sense of scope and zeroing in on
more specifically so for the time being
let's actually set aside the issue of
Dumbledore sexuality not being canonized
and just take it as read Harry Potter is
a big franchise not just in terms of
entries and adaptations but in the sheer
number of characters Wikipedia alone
lists just shy of 200 individually named
characters from the series and that does
not appear to account for things like
the curse child or Pottermore this is a
lot of named characters some big some
small but undeniably numerous and these
roughly 200 characters among them we
have a single homosexual character that
we know of that's one
200 that is half a percent which brings
us to the joyous world of Statistics now
getting accurate measures of what
percentage of the general populace is
lgbtq+ is admittedly difficult this has
to do with being something that has to
be self-reported and there are numerous
reasons for somebody to either choose to
not admit being lgbtq+ or possibly even
be in denial about it to themselves so
statistics vary and range and some
sociologists estimate it could be as
high as 10%
however most stats based on collected
data put it more in the neighborhood of
4 to 5 percent though it could be much
higher but I mean let's keep st. you
things simple let's go low we will use
4% as our baseline if 4% of the populace
is something other than cisgender and
heterosexual then we should be looking
at 8 such characters in the Harry Potter
franchise and again we have only one if
you want to be really generous you could
argue that there are two if you consider
tongs to be gender fluid however it's
worth pointing out that her ability to
change appearance does not appear to be
reflective of any shifting sense of self
so I personally don't buy that one even
though I mean it's worth acknowledging
so we've got half a percent of the name
characters 1% tops
unfortunately when we start looking past
just characters and that relationships
in Harry Potter either sexual or
romantic pairings things get a bit worse
this is actually where the whole thing
spawned from a commenter whose name I'm
I will try and remember to put on screen
because I haven't got a clue how to
pronounce it but in any case they
commented with a list of various couples
in the books and films and what I
actually saw a list of how many
relationships there are in this series
the absence of any deviation from
heterosexuality becomes all the more
glaring I was knocked on my ass by this
to be honest I'll point out I myself had
previously given a pass to Dumbledore
sexuality not being referenced in the
original series on the basis of not many
adult relations
chips being noted at all but when you
see the scope of how many relationships
there are between students between
adults major characters minor things
frankly get while they get harder to
defend I'm going to quickly just rattle
off the depicted or referenced
relationships in the Harry Potter series
and I'll point out I have actually
trimmed this list down quite a bit from
what I was originally given not because
of anything wrong with the examples
provided but if I saw names that I
didn't immediately recognize I took them
off because well because I'm lazy and I
didn't want to cross-reference every
single one of those so keep in mind that
the list I'm about to give you isn't
even comprehensive so for depicted or
overtly referenced relationships in the
main series books and films we have Ron
and Hermoine Ron and lavender Ron and
Padma Hermione and Crum Harry and Ginny
Harry and Cho Harry and Parvati Ginny
and Dean Cho and Cedric floor and bill
Draco and pansy Draco and Astoria this
is referred to as that's this his wife
that we see in the epilogue of the last
film there's Molly and Arthur reason
Weasley recent Tonks Lily and James
Potter Tom Riddle senior and Merapi I
think that's how you pronounce that I I
know there was a love spell but stuff
there's Tom Riddle seniors parents
there's petunia and Vernon Dursley
there's Narcisa and lucius malfoy there
is reg and Mary Cattermole there's
Hermione's parents there's Dean parents
it's mentioned that his father was gone
before his mother could find out if he
was magic or not sheamus's which mother
and mother and muggle father bit of a
nasty shock for him when he found out
Hagrid and Madame Maxine Alison Frank
Longbottom Hagrid's parents in addition
I'm gonna give you the cannon straight
relationships so far in fantastic beasts
and where to find them we have Jacob in
Queenie we have Tina Newt we have Newt
and Lita and finally we have referenced
attractions that didn't actually result
in relationships most famously that
would be Snape and his feeling
for Lily but after that we've got a
whole bunch of groups that frankly I
can't even begin to assign numbers to
such as say every male at the Quidditch
World Cup having the attraction to the
Vilas Ron and basically every other male
in Hogwarts having an attraction to
Fleur many of the girls having an
attraction to Crum searching for
lipsticks so that he can sign their hats
and this is not even getting into the
curse child and the various background
information learned through things like
Pottermore it also doesn't get into
groups of paired off couples at events
like say the Yule Ball and yes and
Berger says specifically I am prepared
to accept that boys and girls dancing at
the start of the ball is simply
traditional but we also clearly see
everybody cutting loose soon after and
it's still all heterosexual pairings
that we see and through all this we have
supposedly one homosexual in Clyde man
whose sexual orientation is yet to be
canonized in either the books or the
films and the person he's attracted to
appears to not have been reciprocal and
coming back to that four percent that I
mentioned before even if I throw out
every crowd and mass attraction that I
mentioned and stick to the relationships
and the attractions between characters
whose names I recognized that's 31
relationships and at a four percent rate
we shouldn't have gotten one
non-heterosexual sexual relationship
somewhere
in just that group of 31 this is the
problem that is by no means limited to
Harry Potter Marvel had Kevin Feige he
made headlines by saying there were two
LGBTQ characters coming up in the Marvel
films not to imply that this isn't a
good thing because it is but much like
how long it was before we had a
non-white or non male hero headline of
film I can't help but sigh and go it's
about damn time if we limit ourselves to
just the films which at the time of
recording this is up through ant-man of
the wasp and suicide TV and Netflix the
MCU consists of again over 200 named
characters by my count it was 217
appearing in 20 films the closest we've
come to lgbtq+ representation in those
films is a deleted scene from thor
ragnarok which would have confirmed
curry as having previously been in a
same-sex relationship if we open things
up to include the shows and Netflix we
get a couple of unambiguous instances of
representation but we also add in
hundreds of more characters so this
still coming up well short of how tiny a
sliver this actually is and please don't
give me the none of these characters are
gay in the comics line they've been
modifying these characters left and
right the MCU version of wasp isn't even
a character in the main continuity of
the comics they pulled the name hope Van
Dyne from an alternate universe villain
and made a totally new character all
right all right now with Star Wars I
stopped counting characters who have
names once I hit 250 but it's got to be
close to 400 if not more and that's
liberating myself to the movies not
touching on the shows the books the
comics the videogames and who knows what
else and in that franchise to date we
have a hint that one character might be
but bisexual in one of the novels I
don't even want to run the numbers on
this and there is a reason that I had
this video focus on Harry Potter most
prominently and I'm only kind of
glossing over a few other examples and I
will get to that in a minute firstly
however I need to put emphasis on this
because people have mistaken my meaning
before I am NOT insisting that any or
all franchises should be mandated or
required to include lgbtq+ characters we
don't have to be in everything in my
mind and he cast large enough that
statistically there should be an LGBTQ
person should at least consider having
one or at least know the reason why they
aren't going to do that I mean I have my
hopes but truly nobody is under any
obligation no author no director no
studio should be forced to represent me
it will be nice but it's not obligatory
nor should it be and I'm putting this
clarification disclaimer here towards
the back end of this because it'll out
any commentary any commenter who accuses
me of wanting to force representation
into everything
not having watched the whole video
before they commented I can be devious I
did not get sorted into Slytherin for no
reason but getting to that reason of why
I put so much focus on Harry Potter
specifically well actually there's two
reasons the first is that unlike Star
Wars or the MCU romantic and
affectionate entanglements is a pretty
significant part of the Harry Potter
narrative partly by the necessity since
we're talking about teenagers and that's
the age most of us at least try to get
that stuff sorted out to some degree but
you can make an argument that
relationships in general are a smaller
negligible part of some of those other
franchises I mentioned or ones like them
in fact that argument has been made with
Rian Johnson saying that quote sexuality
in general is not something that's front
of of the mind in many of these movies
referring to Star Wars I can't say that
he's wrong
however relationships are prominent in
Harry Potter but even beyond that the
fact that Harry Potter is a franchise
it's in a uniquely awkward position and
it's had the author tell us that a
character is gay not a screenwriter
adapting books not a director
visualizing the world not an actor
interpreting a character but the
originator of all of this and she is a
creator who maintains an impressive
level of creative control over a
sprawling franchise even to this day it
has been confirmed by the highest
possible authority on all things Harry
Potter that gay people if not the entire
LGBTQ plus spectrum exists in this
fictional universe and yet despite
hundreds of characters dozens dozens of
relationships and numerous groups and
crowd scenes there has not been a single
non cisgender non-heterosexual character
clearly depicted as being such and when
you take a step back and realize the
size and the scope of this franchise
that's honestly well it is pretty messed
up
and like I said she's not obligated to
include anything of this nature but she
opened the door so when you say that gay
or lgbtq+ whatever if any version of
that exists somewhere in your universe
and your universe is this big and you
somehow still don't have the room to
depict that yeah that's a legitimate
problem because this isn't me just
projecting statistics onto Harry Potter
the franchise brought up well the author
of the franchise
at any rate and again I don't want to
dwell too much on that particular end of
it but if you are going to unless you're
going to just flat-out say those kinds
of characters don't exist here which any
creators in there within their right to
say then once the franchise is this big
it's frustrating and it's isolating
because when you look at something that
big you look at something with 200
characters dozens of relationships and
you can't find a character that speaks
to you on a fundamental reality of who
you are that makes you feel wrong and
that's the thing it's the reason that I
focused on huge franchises because you
know if you write a book even if it's
got enough characters that statistically
somebody should be gay using the base
line that I said it's just it's it's a
book it's your story it's encapsulated
for the length of whatever it is when
you start expanding out into a franchise
multiple entries more and more
characters once you start getting into
the hundreds of characters the more
characters there are and if you can't
find just one one and go that one speaks
to me about this thing that is that
marks me out as unusual and that
ike I potentially get persecuted for it
just makes you feel small it makes you
feel wrong it makes you feel unwanted
because you look at something that big
you go this is a massive universe and
there's no room for me
not every LGBTQ people person
identifying person will feel that some
will some won't but the result is that
it reinforces something that hurts a lot
of people and like I said again there's
this is not about obligation but it is
about delivering on in the case of Harry
Potter specifically I would say a
promise but even if that's not the case
like I said in Star Wars which is a
surprisingly asexual universe actually I
want asexual is the wrong word salud
sexless that's a better term for that
but to still you know go through over a
dozen movies you know if you count the
Ewok stuff
countless comics novels video games
where am I there's a galaxy far far away
and there's no place for me and it's not
that it is overtly banging that into
anybody but it's an undercurrent and
it's an undercurrent that exists in a
lot of media and it's not helped by the
few instances when an LGBTQ person is
present that it often gets a massive
laser-focused put on it you know the
Creator is talking it up in interviews
people doing think pieces on it that
that kind of overt focus honestly
doesn't help because it just lends to a
feeling of well here here's a bone
aren't you aren't you grateful to us for
throwing you this bone and I just wish
there was less of a deal made that's
probably inevitable that a big deal is
gonna be makers this is progress that is
happening like I said I while I'm
annoyed at how long it is taken Marvel
to introduce LGBTQ pose characters into
the movies I am glad they did it I'm not
gonna Pat them on the back for it cuz
for how big that universe is it took too
long and I don't have a final point that
I'm necessarily arriving at but I just
wanted to give you a sense of how big
some of these worlds are that sometimes
creators sometimes other fans assert
that there's no room for lgbtq+ people
there when worlds are this big that's a
weird thing to me I think I'm gonna wrap
it up there thank you very much for
sticking all the way through this now I
tackled these sorts of topics I aim for
monthly if something comes up I'll do it
otherwise but you know there's a ton of
other geek stuff for you to enjoy where
I don't get as heavy on things but in
any case what are your thoughts about
this about whether it's Harry Potter
specifically or just these large
expansive universes in general whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it please
be respectful that's all that I asked
disagree with me I'm happy to to read
and even respond to those comments just
please be respectful and you know the
usual gobbledygook there's a whole bunch
of buttons and links I have a patreon if
you want to financially support this
kind of content you can check all that
if you feel like it
remember folks you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]